Meera Reed: Years ago, in the height of summer,
my father told my brother and me a story.
He only told it once, and he refused to speak
of it ever again.
When he was a young man in the Year of the
False Spring, a great southern lord held the
largest tourney Westeroshad ever seen in the
largest castle Westeros had ever seen.
Knights and lords from across the Seven Kingdoms
made their way, drawn by the spectacle and
the size of the champion's purse.
Even the king was rumored to be attending,
though none had seen him in years.
Ours is a small house, and my father had come
only to be part of the magnificence, whose
like he'd never see again.
One afternoon, he was walking across the field
enjoying the warm spring day, when he was
set upon by three squires.
None were older than fifteen, yet all were
bigger than him.
This was their world, as they saw it, and
he had no right to be there.
They snatched away his spear and knocked him
to the ground, cursing him for a frog-eater.
Every time he tried to rise they shoved him
down and kicked him when he curled up on the
ground.
But then they heard a shout.
"That's my father's man you're kicking!" howled
the she-wolf.
Lyanna Stark, the young daughter of Lord Rickard
Stark, Warden of the North, and my father's
liege lord.
Lyanna laid into the squires with a tourney
sword, scattering them all.
My father was bruised and bloodied, so she
took him back to her tent to clean his cuts
and bind them up with linen.
There he met her brothers — Wild Brandon
who led them, quiet Eddard and Benjen, who
was the youngest of the four.
That evening, there was to be a feast in Harrenhal
to mark the opening of the tourney, and Lyanna
insisted that my father attend, as he was
of high birth with as much a right to a place
on the bench as any other man.
She was not easy to refuse, this wolf maid,
so my father borrowed suitable clothes from
Benjen and went up to the great castle.
Under Harren's great roof, my father ate and
drank with his fellow Northmen.
A black brother beseeched the knights to join
the Night's Watch, to snickers and smiles.
Prince Rhaegar sang a song so sad that it
brought tears to Lyanna's eyes, but when Benjen
teased her for it, she poured wine over his
head.
Lord Baratheon drank down a knight of skulls
and kisses in a wine-cup war.
My father remembered a beautiful woman with
purple eyes who danced with Ser Barristan
Selmy and several others.
As the end of the evening approached, Brandon
Stark asked her for one more dance on his
shy brother's behalf, and so Eddard Stark
shared the last dance of the celebration with
Lady Ashara Dayne.
Abruptly, the hall went quiet.
The Mad King had come after all and was now
entering the hall with his Kingsguard.
He hadn't left the Red Keep in years, and
none could believe the state of him.
His long yellow fingernails, tangled beard,
and ropes of unwashed, matted hair made his
madness plain to all.
Nor was his behavior that of a sane man, for
in the blink of an eye, he could go from hysterical
laughter to weeping to rage.
But when he commanded Ser Jaime Lannister
to kneel before him and swear the oath of
the Kingsguard before half the lords of the
realm, a cheer burst from the crowd, for Ser
Jaime was much admired for his courage, gallantry,
and skill with a sword.
Amidst all this merriment, my father spied
the three squires who'd attacked them attending
their knights.
Lyanna saw them too and pointed them out to
their brothers.
"I could find you a horse and some armor that
might fit," Benjen offered.
My father thanked him but gave no answer.
"Our people sit a boat more often than a horse,
and our hands are made for oars, not lances."
Much as he wished to have his vengeance, he
feared he would only make a fool of himself
and shame his people.
Eddard had offered my father a place in his
tent that night, but before my father slept,
he knelt on a lakeshore looking across the
water to the Isle of Faces and said a prayer
to the Old Gods.
The next day in the tourney, the three knights
whose squires had beaten my father unseated
their opponents and earned a place among the
champions.
But late in the afternoon, as the shadows
grew long, a mystery knight appeared in the
lists.
He was short and clad in ill-fitting armor,
cobbled together from different suits.
On his shield was painted a heart tree of
the Old Gods, a white weirwood with a laughing
red face.
The mystery knight dipped his lance before
the king and rode to the end of the lists,
where the five champions held their pavilions.
You can guess the three he challenged.
Whoever the mystery knight was, the Old Gods
gave strength to his arm.
All three knights fell before him.
None were well-loved, so the common folk cheered
the Knight of the Laughing Tree, as the new
champion was soon called.
When the fallen foes sought to ransom their
horses and armor, the Knight of the Laughing
Tree's voice boomed through his helm and told
them: "Teach your squires honor.
That shall be ransom enough."
Once the defeated knights chastised their
squires sharply, their horses and armor were
returned, and so my father's prayer was answered.
The king was furious.
In his madness, he suspected a traitor in
his midst.
Perhaps even the newly-made Ser Jaime Lannister,
whom he had already sent back to the Red Keep.
That night, the king asked Lord Robert Baratheon
to take to the lists and unmask the mystery
knight, declaring him no friend of his.
But the next morning, when the heralds blew
their trumpets, and the king took his seat,
the Knight of the Laughing Tree had vanished.
All they ever found was his painted shield,
hanging abandoned in a tree.
My father's tale ended here.
He never spoke more of Harrenhal, though he
must have seen Prince Rhaegar's victory.
Some whisper that Prince Rhaegar himself had
arranged to the entire tourney in secret as
a way to gather the great lords and address
his father's apparent madness, perhaps even
remove him from the Iron Throne.
But when I asked my father about this, he
only shrugged sadly.
What Rhaegar intended, none can say.
But all know what he did.
Barristan Selmy: "Barristan the Bold" they
call me to my face.
I know what they say behind my back; Barristan
the Old.
I find myself visited by the faces of the
kings I have served.
The faces of those I swore to protect.
The faces of those I failed.
Young Prince Aerys.
For twenty years, his reign was peaceful and
prosperous.
Aerys was well-loved by his people and respected
by his lords.
But as years went on, Aerys' temper soured.
He became obsessed with dragons and fire,
and the swords of the Kingsguard couldn't
defend him from the enemies he saw lurking
in every shadow.
My king went mad.
But there was hope; his son and heir.
Prince Rhaegar was everything a kingdom could
hope for in a ruler; he was strong but gentle,
wise and cautious, and a good friend.
No matter the wounds Aerys dug into the realm,
we had faith that his son would sew it back
together again when he ascended the throne.
Then came Lord Whent's tourney at Harrenhal,
the largest ever in Westeros.
I unhorsed every man against me until only
Prince Rhaegar remained.
We each set our feet in our saddles and lowered
our lances and charged, and I fell.
Muddy and bruised, I then watched Rhaegar
present Lyanna Stark with the victor's crown
of roses, though she was betrothed to Robert
Baratheon and Rhaegar himself was married
to Elia Martell.
We all know what happened after.
If I had I been a bit quicker with my lance,
had I chosen a faster horse, perhaps I could
have spared the kingdom from the destruction
that came after.